millions of Californians now have more
rights than ever when it comes to their
personal online data and that includes
the right to find out what's being
collected and ensure it is not being
sold CBS News contributor and wired
editor-in-chief Nick Thompson requested
the trove of data that was collected on
him and included his address his phone
number and an order of bean burritos and
a Tejada salad from his family's
favorite Mexican restaurants Nick good
morning that and much more I assume was
in this trove so what'd you find well so
I requested data from all kinds of
companies the one that had that
particular order was a company called
sift which is a company that analyzes
whether a purchase is likely to be fraud
or not and so it had all kinds of data
from what I ordered when I ordered it
the browser I was using the direction my
phone was tilted the address I was at
the gravitational forces on the phone
everything was hundreds of pages of loss
so is what is uses data like that Nick
well if you're trying to identify fraud
all those indicators could have some
impact right so whether you've changed
the language setting on your browser the
currency you've paid and could indicate
international fraud the direction you're
holding the phone could indicate whether
you're a real human or not whether
there's a human signature and the
position of the phone so all of that
data and even if we can't even think of
it it's possible the computers analyzing
millions of data points could find using
artificial intelligence indicators of
fraud so if if a person were peeking in
your blinds and recording on a notebook
all the things that the phone was
tracking on you you get creeped out but
absolutely finding all of this with the
computer tracking you are you creeped
out so I had two two responses when I
saw this data I thought this is crazy I
hate that all these companies know
exactly how I was holding my phone and
then I thought well wait a second if
this reduces fraud yes
reducing fraud is actually good for the
people who aren't committing fraud and
the truth is I did order that burrito
but what if they what if the company
knows that when you're lying down for
example you make more irrational
purchases and therefore they're gonna
charge you a higher price whenever they
know your phone is at this angle right
so if it's being used for that purpose
incredibly creepy I don't know it's not
that yeah we don't know if in use for
that purpose so the question is do you
allow it to be used for no purposes do
you allow it to be used for every
purpose or do you try to regulate the
purposes for which it can be used and
cannot be used and that's what's so good
about the California law is we're
actually starting to get legislators
thinking about this stuff
passing policy has this affected the way
you use your devices at all not yet it's
made me a little more nervous I mean I'm
pretty good on privacy I know how to set
up the best privacy settings how to use
VPNs and all of that so I'm not too
concerned but it does make me a little
bit wary just knowing that even I as the
editor wired they're collecting hundreds
of data points that I had no idea about
be concerned
you